[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to
this edition of bone end of the week
where we break down your vote
for bonehead of the week we have some
great contenders this week yeah i mean
fantastic boneheads oh baby you don't
you don't hardly get more boneheaded
than these boneheads oh man of course
i know you got some new news on elon
musk that we'll get to um we have
marjorie taylor green marjorie perjury
green and then uh uh
the fox news's local nazi uh laura
ingraham i'm not making that up when i
say nazi like everyone's no come on i'm
like i'm serious her brother brother
brother said she's a monster
right well i mean they they had they had
mine comp right there on the coffee
table yeah right i mean that's that's
the thing that's the thing um she's
throwing her waves out in a very
specific
uh form or or way you know like uh
so let's let's get to laura let's get
the laura ingraham um
stuff out of the way here real quick
because i wanna i think i've got a clip
of it but the gist of it is why we're
talking about her she
she actually said that she kept her
mother
working till she was 75 to pay off her
student loan debt yeah
to pay off the loan debt she basically
was like this my mother had to pay off
the loan debts until she was 73.
now that logic basically says well
my mother had to do it or i had to do it
uh everyone else should have to the
problem with that is that as a society
right as a group of people that want to
better the next generation right because
republicans are always like oh the uh
the the budget is too high it's gonna
cause a bunch of financial issues for
the the next generation the next
generation we got to save our children
we got to do this right
but
like republicans they're complete
hypocrites because what ends up
happening is they say oh no no i had to
pay for my way through college which by
the way for a lot of these boomers and
older people
it was very
uh affordable okay
and the other side of it is that when
they say
oh you have to pay
they feel like oh well i had to do the
work you should also do the work right i
shouldn't make it easier for you i
should make getting education affordable
i shouldn't making uh or i i shouldn't
give you the ability to
to better prepare yourself for the
workforce to get a good job to get a
higher salary instead you should go into
debt crippling debt with with the
interest rates and in tuition that rise
higher than inflation right so you look
at this and they just say well
i did it so you should too which is i
think a most uh idiotic way to think
about this because at the end of the day
we should be thinking about how to
better everyone that comes after us
right we want to leave a place for them
to live to exist and if we continue now
this pattern of like well i did it you
have to there's gonna be nothing left
and no one's gonna be able to follow
follow suit with a proper education or
to get a good uh salary or or what have
you like there's a long list of things
that this like targets right which goes
to getting good housing right and
getting stability in your life these are
all things that republicans uh preach
but don't actually follow
well of course they don't well here's
the clip and and uh margie margie she
wants me to point out that it's that
it's a hard g margin only mention that
because margie marge
but margie midas margie thank you for
the super no relation to the other yes
and and by the way gabe everyone's
pointing out that that the youtube
youtube um you can put a poll up on
youtube i everyone i pointed this out to
the executive producer
and the team of executive producers that
put together the bone end of the week
poll
and they really they really kind of
flattened me last week on no no no i
didn't flatten you i just said oh you're
making you not you the the production
team you know yeah i've got a group of
interns that do all the work for me
right right all the pay that i
that i pay with nothing because like
republicans i support child labor no i
don't uh but
i it's not that i flattened your idea
what i said was yeah oh you're just
giving me more work to do you're making
my job harder because now i got to go to
the other part
now you have to continue with the chat
now you have to contend with the chat
here yeah
i it's not me and i promise i did not
see this thing i did not see this thing
it's not me i did you wait hold on did
you put a pull-up on youtube that i
didn't see no no no no i mean you go to
youtube check it out i i did not see
this thing at all these people know that
there's [ __ ] we can do it for next
week we can do it for next we'll do it
we'll try it next week yeah i'll just
i'll just tabulate everything together
yeah you'll have to do math you'll have
to do math it'll be horrible it'll be
horrible uh andrea thank you for the
super chat uh thanks for letting me hang
out for lunch when i can marge
um
martial arts as well oh my gosh thank
you andrew for the super chat let's go
to this video really quick um and let's
listen to what this
[ __ ] bonehead says
about her mom
working or i don't know my mom was a
waitress until she was 73 somehow she
got herself to the poll and voted on
election day i mean
you know i don't this whole thing of
having elections for weeks and months
before the election so this is a little
different video than that her mom works
till she 73 you know this is she's
talking about how they're still alive i
i don't know i'm not really
as a millionaire which i'm assuming she
is she was like i mean like i get i get
the whole thing is like if you're
working through your whole life and you
want to still have that sense of like
uh purpose you want to continue working
right right well a lot of people a lot
of people work in retirement they they
just want something
and if that's the thing you want to do
that's totally fine i don't know what
the situation is but i also have a
feeling like uh laura ingraham will just
be like oh no i'm not going to i'm not
going to financially assist you mom
because you got to pull yourself over
your bootstraps i'm not gonna give you
the money i'm not gonna pay for you to
live somewhere you gotta do it yourself
so meanwhile her mom's like [ __ ] my life
i gotta go do all this work myself
because my goddamn nazi daughter won't
help me out right
well i mean i mean laura ingraham
probably is strapped for cash i mean she
probably doesn't no i'm just kidding she
makes all kinds of money propagating her
her putin [ __ ] and her nazi propaganda
okay let's let's move on from the the
local nazi at fox news and let's go to
the next bonehead because you have some
news um about elon musk before we get to
the dishonorable mention and the outlook
duck uh i definitely want to make sure
we talk about elon everyone knows uh
we've been dogging on elon for a while
on this show and we actually believe
that he will not buy twitter is right
that's my personal opinion but yeah yeah
what is the new news about elon and him
buying selling tesla that sort of thing
so this was actually something i meant
to uh bring up yesterday which is like
the dip in the stock uh that happened
for tesla right everyone was like well
what's happening who's selling like
there's a massive sell-off are there
investors yes it is is it investors who
don't have confidence in the fact that
this guy said i am 100 committed to
advancing electric vehicle and the
industry uh you know with tesla
and when you see your ceo
uh go off and do some personal you know
like you know a little pet project to go
by twitter
and that you know distracts him
from tesla and also there's a lawsuit
that's against tesla uh that's happening
this fall so like that's a pretty big
important thing that needs to kind of
keep focus on but
um i'll talk about that in a sec um
but for for investors they're like well
if elon's distracted then he can't focus
on advancing the company and making me
money right and that's what the issue is
here so then on on tuesday everyone's
like whoa dude stock goes down right and
they're up again there is uh investor
kind of people clamoring to be like i'm
out i'm out i don't trust this anymore
this is bad news you know also driving
down the stock to say like if the value
of the stock you know dollar per share
or per per share um
ends up being sure
lower than what was agreed upon by the
financial institutions and elon to
leverage and then the deal right in the
right right right in the end because the
deal says like basically again i don't
know what the actual number is i think
it's like sub 750 is when the deal goes
belly up to say like you actually can't
leverage against this company because
the equity that you're you're actually
proposing is less than what you agreed
upon and so if that happens then the
banks
take their commitment because again it's
nothing that's in writing like it's not
a contract that says you have to give in
this money they said if you can
uh satisfy this financially here and and
commit to this then we will also commit
to giving you this money well i think
this is all bad news for this deal and
it is more indication that this thing's
gonna go way south um number one there
was talk yesterday about four billion
but you're gonna you're gonna tell us
that it's almost nine billion of tesla
stock that elon sold is that right
exactly so what ended up happening was
yeah so when you as you know an investor
or as a ceo right you've got you've got
shares you sell those you have a day or
two
of buffer
to announce it right so he sells he
sells about four billion
on tuesday
and then two days later he has to report
what those why does he have to report
because he's the ceo
but well i mean that's one of the main
things for sure because you want to know
this is some more videos selling off a
bunch of stock and you'll be like what
the hell is going on does he have
information that we need to and that's
what i was really trying to make the
point yesterday is that if elon musk was
really serious about buying twitter
which he's not he's not serious because
if he was truly serious he would take 18
to 24 months to put himself in a
position to where he could buy twitter
and twitter would probably be okay with
that like if he's gonna give him 45
billion or he actually was serious about
it and he wanted to buy twitter and all
this [ __ ] he would have he would have
put himself in a position where he
wasn't the tesla ceo he could have sold
off the stock over a period of time that
would not have uh negatively affected
tesla and pissed off the investors there
he would have done these things if he
was actually serious or if he's not a
[ __ ]
bonehead now
i believe this is the problem that he's
gonna have
he is selling off a stock in a company
that he is the ceo he's pissing off the
investors but also what he's doing is
he's selling a very prop what was a
profitable stock before he started this
nonsense
for a for a company that's not
profitable and also this morning we're
hearing that there's no way that
twitter's profits are going to be able
to carry this [ __ ] debt which means
he's selling off a [ __ ] stock of a
company that can carry its own debt
right who is servicing its debt who is
able to pay its [ __ ] bills who is it
that is solvent they're in the black
and he's trading away nine billion
dollars and confidence in that company
for a company that may or may not be
able to service the debt that he is
going to take on and here's what i mean
by that
twitter is profitable
it is but the problem is is there's not
enough profit to pay the [ __ ] banks
their money yeah so when you go take a
loan the bank doesn't just give it to
you for free it's not like when elon
takes government money uh in subsidies
for his electric cars the government's
not going to give
or gets paid
the satellites that he helped put over
ukraine right he's like i gave it to you
guys like no actually the government
gave you money i need to fund that
exactly they're not going to subsidize
his twitter deal right exactly so in the
bank is the one that's gonna loan the
money so they they're a private industry
and in capitalism we all know that
there's a margin and that margin is
profit [ __ ] right and the bank's not
gonna
not going to do this deal if they do not
think their margin is going to be kept
there's no [ __ ] way if the bank
thinks he's going to default on this
thing and if the math doesn't add up
where number one elon musk there's no
confidence that he can number one run
tesla and make decisions that um on a
public company the bank is not going to
make the bet that elon can make good
decisions on a privately owned company
where he's not held to sec rules and
regulations and he's not held to certain
regulations when you have a publicly
owned company there's no way the bank's
going to take that deal number one
number two the bank is not going to put
themselves in a position where their
loan cannot be serviced they're not
gonna do it if anyone out there has went
and got a loan they do a credit check
yes it may be like for a hou but for a
mortgage you got to provide so much more
documentation to make sure that you can
service that debt that is what is
happening right now right now the banks
and all the agents the government
agencies twitter themselves they're
making sure that elon musk and services
thing and let me tell you something him
selling nine billion dollars worth of
tesla stock
basically overnight and surprising
people with this
is not a good sign that he can service
this so that's the other thing too is
like there's that there's the two-day
you have to report it within two days
right so he sells it on tuesday
yesterday or two days after the fact and
says oh uh elon musk has sold four and a
half roughly four and a half billion
worth of of shares right
and people like oh [ __ ] because one the
i think the most important thing that
people need to know here is elon has
gone on the record multiple times and
said i
as elon musk will be the last person to
pull out money from tesla
it's a bad signal to investors when your
ceo who has in the past said one i will
completely 100 devote myself to tesla
and its operations and two
says i will be the last one to take
money out
and then when you see he goes ah you
know what i'm gonna actually buy this
other company that i want to be the ceo
of and i'm gonna sell shares of this
company to to help fund this purchase
and then on top of that we find out
today that it's not only four and a half
billion or like four billion it ends up
being closer to eight and a half billion
jump again yeah because so so he's
doubled
he's double killed his confidence here
like right exactly because again there's
that two day period where you have to go
from execution of the sale to reporting
of the sale to the sec so what ends up
happening here is you go the 26th to the
28th and then he also sold on the 27th
and he also sold on the 28th and today
new filings come out that show him
selling those things on the 27th and the
28th which gets him to eight and a half
billion and now he's and you know last
night he reported he was like the the
way that he phrased it was
somebody called him out for uh selling
the actual uh tesla shares right for
four billion and he goes as of today
there will be or or rather as of right
now there will be no more selling of
tesla after today right
which the way it's raised would show you
that okay
got it okay he's not going to sell past
the 26 but then there's the gap of the
27th and the 28th of april which were
thursday and wednesday and after he's
alluding to that but he's not telling
people outright that he sold also on the
27th and the 28th three days in a row to
get eight and a half billion what he's
going to do is he's just going to let
those filings come out publicly because
the sec has to right well and that's
that type of lack of transparency is
[ __ ] up one that's what the bank is
going to be terrified of here and also
tesla might punish him if he's not
careful i mean we've surmised that
there's no real is there any evidence of
that yet but i mean other than people
just being absolutely pissed and and
so i mentioned earlier there's a lawsuit
that is actually against elon musk when
it comes to tesla so he made an
agreement in 2018 to um
to successfully achieve certain goals at
the company right and he would receive i
think it's 56 billion dollars um
for
for achieving this right it was a 56
billion dollar pay package from tesla um
bonus right now here's the problem now
it's 56 with the b billion
billion that's what he was as if
everyone gets a everyone gets a couple
of billion dollars in a business if you
do your job right come on man come on no
big deal
so what ends up what ends up happening
here in the situation is there's a
lawsuit that is
against
elon musk
because in the first line of the
contract it says you're going to be a
full-time ceo and devote substantially
time to the business affairs and the
company you're not going to try to be
some celebrity who does this and does
this and whatever you've agreed in 2018
it was
rubber stamped that you're the ceo and
you're committing 100
full-time to this company to make sure
that it achieves its success which means
you have to go all the way to 2028 to
get the full payout of this 10-year
package and what ends up happening is an
investor says well you're not committed
so now there's a lawsuit that is going
to be taken to court in october which is
around the same time that this deal for
twitter is going to at in its in its
shortest time span will be agreed and
and finalized
which if you compound both these things
together only helps this lawsuit because
what it shows is that the investor is
actually right in his assumption that
he's not actually committing 100 to
tesla he's not making sure that he's
he's committed all of his
bandwidth resources you know brain power
to making sure that tesla becomes the
number one best
electric vehicle company out there so i
love how you but i love how you put
brain power in a sentence with elon musk
it really is it really is i mean all for
it's you know it's just because elon
stands out there and those bros i think
he's a genius right so again this is
what's happening you've got this deal
that's supposed to be finally finalized
by
in the quickest form is done by october
you've also got this lawsuit for a 56
billion dollar uh bonus payout package
for a 10-year contract that says i elon
musk i'm committed to this tesla company
100 percent and making sure that it is
successful
does that mean does that mean like um
you wouldn't buy like a social media
company maybe and be the ceo and solo i
don't know i don't know maxwell thank
you thank you for the super
and we sticker maxwell
appreciate it let's let's move on um we
have some we have some non-newcomers
here for dishonorable mention alphacut
um dishonorable mention maddie cawthorne
oh my god you talking about
do you have that link what is the what
is this video that you're going to send
me um
so it appears to be in a like a car or
something because we know this week we
know this week he got caught with a
loaded firearm in an airport this is the
second time right um not only that
it is it was revealed over the weekend
um well i guess it was actually a week
ago today
that he was on a royal caribbean cruise
and he was caught in pictures wearing a
bra i guess
which but it's nothing
just it just it seems to go against all
the rhetoric that madison cawthorne
actually
says there was another video of him out
there maybe smoking a blunt or cigar
and there's there's a lot of video out
there of him and one of his aides i i
forget his name offhand i think it's
stephen
smith or something like that i'm not
real sure i might i might have got that
name wrong but is one of his aides uh
went to amsterdam with him
and they were they were releasing a lot
of video that way it seems like to me
that republicans are behind this not not
the lib extreme democrats that it's the
republicans that are actually trying to
destroy
madison gotham now some people have
also i don't know if you mentioned this
one but there's also the insider trading
situation yeah too you're right what
explain that real quick um why we're on
investing
yeah uh i mean while we're on red pill
investing the quick and dirty of it is
madison cawthorne uh
he i believe it's a lawsuit right now
that is against him uh also potent or or
rather there is uh he took an action
there's a consequence um you know
decided to act on certain information
and is involved in an insider insider
trading scheme um and is now being
investigated with like the the bitcoin
the the let's go right brandon
let's go brandon
because what ends up happening is there
are multiple people involved there's the
race car driver the guy that everyone's
like oh let's go brain and that all that
was the commercial where they posted the
let's go brandon coin on the right yeah
yeah
yeah so he did an instagram post or a
tweet i think it was instagram post
where he like was like oh tomorrow's
gonna be popping off or whatever it is
right
and
uh then the
the race car driver you know
was was talking it up and then the coin
goes public you know it has an ico which
is a as a you know it's it's basically
like the equivalent of an ipo but for
for um startups right for no we're not
for startups but you have an ipo for
startups or companies but then you have
an ico for um for crypto crypto okay you
got you got you just just has a
different acronym because it's got a
difference right right so basically he
introduced this coin for crypto and was
using his own platform to publish or to
to promote it and to upsell and to hype
it up and then you know then it becomes
a whole thing of like oh are you buying
selling you know when when are you doing
these things how much you making the
whole question so
he took an action and now there's a
consequence you know
right and i think someone's referred him
to the ethics committee in congress for
it even um here is it it is stephen
smith is the name of the uh patriot
takes has this video right this is the
video that i've used your schedule which
is like an assistant right and he's an
aide or something like that yeah he
works he works for madison governor
right right exactly yeah this is the
video and steven smith is holding the
phone here and
not to give too much away but
madison cawthron is in the driver's seat
it appears and they kind of are making
jokes it's hard to know what they're
making jokes about but then watch at the
very end where the the person holding
the phone stephen smith hand check right
now i i'm actually not sure how
significant this is other than in
republican politics i i really i don't
know what they're talking about and
they're quoting a movie i have no
[ __ ] idea
i have no
no idea what is being uh if this is if
he's quoting something or if he's just
you know making fun of something i have
no idea and i and i honestly i don't
know if these two are closeted and
they're they're having a homosexual
relationship which again nothing is
wrong with that if that's who you are i
mean i mean right i don't i actually
don't give a [ __ ] about that i really
don't care because that's the thing
nobody on our side cares about that [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] if if they if they
are having sex right they're boning each
other if they're having sex filled
orgies if he's wearing bras i don't give
a [ __ ] the thing that gets me the most
is when the hypocrisy of it all and
really it goes back to this stupid
[ __ ] boneheaded thing that he the
video that we showed yesterday of him in
the airport in dc talking about don't
accidentally carry loaded guns in your
backpack this is your stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you people running around the
country demonizing
lgbtq people and making literally
legislating them into a position where
they are ostracized from society you are
making it to where it's a dangerous
place in america for someone to live who
identifies as whatever they want whether
it's a certain person they love or
certain person they want to marry if if
if they are if they want to be a man
they want to be a woman you're making it
[ __ ] dangerous for them and then in
private in private you may or you may
not be doing the exact same thing that
you're ostracizing people for right you
[ __ ] that's the same [ __ ] with
the gun where you're making this
off-handed joke about accidentally
having a loaded gun in a backpack and
then and then [ __ ] pointing at
liberals saying you're the reason why
there's a gun problem because there's
not enough guns and you liberals aren't
strong enough and smart enough and all
this [ __ ] which is
right which is
is so is so disgusting and so irritating
and frustrating because earlier this
week we watch a a baseball game with
kids right and you hear gunfire in the
background and instead of having a place
where families and friends can get
together and watch the kids just have
fun and play baseball and you know i'm
sure you played baseball as a kid right
i remember playing baseball as a kid up
until high school and having like this
is a great moment in my life where i was
able to make friends and have great
experiences instead of dodging bullets
exactly and so the id and so the idea of
like oh liberals are the reason we have
gun problems and the only reason to
solve a a gun problem is you know a bad
guy with more guns
more guys more guns throw more guns of a
problem
bullets flying everywhere has had more
bullets flying exactly you got don jr
last week you did a video on it with him
in greitens and they're shooting these
targets saying that oh liberals watch
out like i destroyed that [ __ ]
we're making we're making death threats
against a group of people and you're
just shooting a static object great for
you [ __ ] right you you shot a thing
that was that was sitting still you shot
a target great i don't give a [ __ ] but
when you start saying liberals watch out
or or were coming for you or whatever
the [ __ ] narrative might be with guns
because all of a sudden now we're just
what is this the greatest game where
we're hunting humans right what the [ __ ]
is this well and then and and it's the
same hypocrisy it's the same [ __ ]
when you see madison caught throwing in
his aid whether they're homosexual or
not
because really honestly i just think
they're joking i don't actually right i
don't actually believe this video is not
enough evidence for me to believe that
madison gotham or his age is homosexuals
they're not the thing that the thing
that ben shapiro's the kurt charlie
kurtz the tucker carlson's of the world
they're afraid of that's what that whole
tanning their balls were that [ __ ]
was is they are they are horrified and
terrified of their insecurity of their
homosexual tendencies and they are they
they internalize them and they [ __ ]
outward project them towards people that
they hate because
oh yeah well i was sitting in my car and
we were joking about being homosexual
and that scares the ever-loving [ __ ] out
of me that someone might find that out
or that i might be a homosexual because
i joked about it you do not have to just
because you joke about being homosexual
does not make you one and who gives a
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] leave these
[ __ ] people alone and stop being such
[ __ ] hypocrites and by the way
madison got thorn by the way you can eat
[ __ ] is what you can do you can eat [ __ ]
and you cannot be in congress because
you do not need to be anywhere near any
kind of lever of power not just because
you were you were a [ __ ] bigot but
because you were a [ __ ] crooked piece
of [ __ ] with your insider trading thank
you uh
mj for the super chat there we really
appreciate you joining in every day you
want to hear the jingle we'll we're
going to do the jingles we're going to
do the jungle today
um let's go one more let's go to the uh
alpha cuck first oh
speaking of ben shapiro we just talked
about the alpha ben shapiro benny boy
being completely terrified of his
homosexual tendencies i mean absolutely
terrified of sexual sexuality
terrified terrified that a woman that a
woman would be aroused gabe
and be and be terrified
be terrified
of someone's speech because we've seen
we've seen the video where he blocked
someone's speech i think that's why he's
the
yeah yeah yeah yeah is it i mean what we
did yes that is 100 why he is on the
list there and you know just from just
to want to remind everyone ben shapiro
is the type of guy that when he walks
into the room he dries it all up he just
so he just sucks the moisture right out
of the room
let me show you what's left with a dry
ass [ __ ] let me see if i can find this
video of uh ben shapiro here uh drying
up the room
uh
as it were big thank you to kathy
oh yeah thank you kevin
super sticker
um here is the clip let me get it
forwarded here to where they uh
to where they where they don't like the
free speech here's the clip now to give
context and this is a clip of ben
shapiro speaking and this this person is
a a outright woker as uh he he probably
walks into the pool with the stairs and
he probably eats you know vegetables and
stuff um but what happens here at the
end is ben shapiro is trying to shut him
up and they actually take the microphone
away from so much so that they're
putting their hands in front of it not
letting them speak like you know
hampering is freedom of speech yeah
they're silencing they're suppressing
right let's see the republican party
wouldn't do that no absolutely not well
the video of course is going to take a
little bit to load of course what the
hell is going on
uh the internet here i actually thought
gabe i told you this morning that there
were storms here i didn't know yeah i'd
lose power or not but i haven't it was
gonna it was gonna be like it was gonna
be the gabe sanchez show today yeah i
know well here well you know it happens
here here's here's it well anyways the
damn video isn't working uh here i'll
i'll download it and i'll upload it well
um
let's let's uh um because basically what
happens is let me refresh here let me
see if i can refresh and get but anyways
what happens in the video
is that this person is speaking and he's
speaking about wokeness and being woke
and what and that the right wing like
ben shapiro always defines it as the
wrong [ __ ] thing like
like here here now it's working let's
see oh it's working okay i just
downloaded it for you man
here it is
okay so we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to stop here because this is going
nowhere what's up
i'm gonna have to stop with this with
you because this is going nowhere and me
any means because we talked about this
the other day it means it's going
nowhere because it's not helping his
narrative and he really he's going to
lose the argument here so he wants to
shut this guy up but watch what happens
physically
boo the crowd crowd's trying to silence
this guy
all the all the free speech advocates in
the crowd are trying to silence it now
look look here they're holding their
hand physically over the microphone
you're right right cover the mic elon
musk's free speech here this is elon
musk style free speech if you want to
know so that is why ben shapiro ended up
on the um if you don't say what we like
then we silence your speech that's right
that's right that's why ben shapiro
ended up as the alpha cuck because he
does he does cuck a lot
um and and it happens it happens now we
go to ultimately uh our winner who is
marjorie taylor green or marjorie
perjury green i used to call her
marjorie foot green yeah maybe
yeah margaery or perjury taylor green
yeah boy do we have a lot of we do we
have a lot of video on oh boy our video
does not stop
where do we want to start do we want to
start with the video that she posted
that she thought was a good idea to post
online yeah we do that one maybe we
played the other video that i found this
week you know uh oh yeah yeah yeah okay
well let's let's start let me see if i
can find the one uh what has happened
give people context here this video that
she posted where she she's walking
appears she's walking down the the
sidewalk
at the united states capital um and a
reporter named john acosta is approaches
her now she
she acts as if
um he's following her and she says like
don't
don't um
don't don't follow me or something like
that what what is she saying in this
video she was uh don't well by the end
of the video she's telling acosta be
like you're harassing me this is
harassment you're harassing me he's like
i'm just asking you a question right i'm
just asking you a [ __ ] question um
which he's entitled to do which um
he approaches her in the street
[Music]
here i i got i got it look i got it here
okay let's let's see we got it here here
is the video where he is
he's a reporter he's a journalist here
um and she's on a public sidewalk and he
has the right to ask her a question she
doesn't have to she doesn't have to
answer but he has the right to ask her
also i guess you also said
you didn't recall calling nancy pelosi a
traitor now the context here too is this
video is being recorded by one of her
staff members i guess is that right is
that what's going on here yeah yeah this
is it there seems to be a couple
different people
this is this is marjory taylor green's
video like this is her her aide is
recording this video uh
with the belief that this is going to
make margaret taylor green seem more
sane
oh yeah okay well let's see
how sane she seems
what does that matter i mean i guess
that's actually kind of the point is he
does have a show um but she goes on to
say here um you know and and they look
through the text message this is like
four minutes long i'm not going to play
the whole thing but let's let's play a
little more and let's get to the part
where he's looking up the text messages
watch what she says
all fairness you try to present this
image of me to your viewers
he tries to present well we're just
trying to get some answers did you send
a text
asking for the president to declare
martial law did you read it you know i
don't recall those being my text
messages but have you read the text
message that is
that you're referring to i did because
it actually says if you it was
misspelled
he really digs into her there he's like
you're a [ __ ] idiot but yeah it does
it does seem to say um and and she's
she's trying to what she's trying to
frame up here which she's not going to
be able to do in a court of law if this
ends up being in the court of law for
perjury um which i don't know if it will
or not i'm not real sure how that
administrative hearing works and her
being under oath down there i'm not sure
um in georgia that that we streamed
eight hours last week and you can go to
the youtube channel and then subscribe
to the youtube channel and see
that that footage we actually did a cut
of the footage but it leaves in almost
the majority of her testimony that day
down in georgia on her staying on the
ballot or being taken off the ballot but
and that's what he's talking about here
is is this the the text message that has
been revealed after she testified on the
stand that she did not call for martial
law which the text messages proves that
she did that's why she's being so
offhanded here right like she's like oh
what did you read them did you read them
because they might say or might not say
and i don't recall if i sent them i mean
it says that i sent them but it's on
cnn.com or something let's listen
if you read it correctly jim your
problem is you're lying again right now
you can't read it i do not know on those
things that's what that text message is
one of those liars on television and
people hate it they can't stand the
liars they can't stand they can't stand
people telling the truth when they don't
want to hear the truth that's what she's
saying that's what she's saying
i'm not the one saying i don't know i
don't recall it well the supposed text
message
quoted what does it say i don't know on
those things
the only way to save our republic is for
trump to call for marshall so she text
the only way to save our republic is for
trump to call for martial law so she's
calling on trump to call for martial law
but then she's debating the the the the
words after i don't know about those
things and come on yeah she's like what
does the text say i don't know about
this thing
right i don't know on those things i
just wanted you to tell him i don't know
on this thing is that what that says it
says i don't know on this thing
she makes it seem like she well she
believes that she's making a point here
right right well she's getting very
defensive
about these text messages that were
supposedly allegedly sent from marjory
taylor green okay this is someone who
has clearly supported the insurrection
and overthrowing the government and uh
you know rejecting the certification
of votes for
the election
you know and then at the end of that she
has the audacity and i and i think he'll
show the video in a second but she has
the audacity to claim and accuse jim
acosta of harassing when he just asks
questions he claimed it and but i want
to show you video here gabe right of the
same thing that martin she's claiming
that this was harassment but i want to
show here joe joe actually uh jojo from
jurors post this while marjorie taylor
green is accusing jim acosta of stalking
and harassing her for asking questions
about martial law a reminder she both
stalked and harassed david hogg a
survivor of the deadly high school
shooting uh right um the the
shooting at marjory stoneman douglas
down in florida
and david hogg was in washington dc this
is before she was actually
a congressperson this was before she was
elected to congress she was following
him around the city um and and saying
these things so if
jim acosta a reporter and journalist
calling and are following her and asking
questions near the capitol is harassment
i wonder what this is
why are you supporting the red flag laws
by the way david hogg is actually in
washington dc at this time
to to go to congress which is his right
again to lobby members as a private
citizen i i believe um or maybe even
part of an organization but to go to
washington to lobby members of congress
for gun safety and she is mad that he is
lob
this is what she's mad at this kid david
at this time is in high school right he
just survived a school shooting from
high school he was dodging bullets right
and she's mad she's mad that she doesn't
have the right to go into high schools
our people doesn't have the right to go
in high schools to sling bullets at high
school students and he's trying he's
there to try to stop
gun violence at high schools and mass
shootings in high schools and she hates
him for it listen
if scott peterson the resource officer
in parkland had done his job
then nicholas cruz wouldn't have killed
anybody in your high school or at least
protected them jesus so in other words
what she's saying as long as as long as
another person shoots another human
being then then
forget about forget about crews actually
getting the gun or or being able to have
access to that and forget about that
forget about that
lay that
lay that problem aside for a second the
problem really is is that there wasn't
enough gunfire really right that's the
problem it's it's like if we analyze the
situation it's not the fact of yeah the
source of where the source came like
it's we're not going to i i address this
systemically and and fix the problem
we're just going to put a band-aid on it
and say well the real problem not the
actual problem but they're a belief from
what the real problem is and then she
goes and she harasses this teenager
who's literally you can see like
look i'm not gonna show the whole video
but look she's following around across
crosswalks uh in into different areas of
the city and this is not and the thing
is like this type of behavior from
audrey taylor green is not new like
she's been doing this like you look at
that when she was running in a race in
georgia
the person that she was running against
had to drop out because of one the
goddamn q
followers that were harassing stalking
death threats and margaret taylor green
said nothing she was in full support you
know he was one that didn't say a thing
you remember this video a while back
where the democrats are trying to take a
picture on the uh on the capitol steps
and she was yelling and screaming vile
[ __ ] things while they were just
trying to take a picture like she is
harassing the [ __ ] out of them she has
just issues they're just trying to take
a picture like i don't know if she needs
anger management or she needs some sort
of therapy but marjorie taylor green has
one too many screws loose in her head
she could use a cold pair of handcuffs
around her wrist probably actually oh
yeah but
um let's go to this next video because
this is the one that uh
actually gave us our title for today
jamie raskin destroys marge is that
right is this the one where she makes
comments and jamie raskin basically
burns her to the ground is that what
this video is this is it okay let's this
is about two minutes and 20 seconds so
let's
we're gonna watch this whole thing
because jamie raskin absolutely destroys
her here
tact it's a shame it's a tragedy i yield
back the remainder of reserve
uh gentlemen gentlemen's time is expired
gentleman from pennsylvania reserves
gentlemen from maryland is recognized mr
speaker the united states of america
just witnessed witnessed the most
astonishing spectacle
we are here to debate
aid to the people of ukraine defending
themselves against a massive invasion by
vladimir putin
and his army
then
the minority puts up the distinguished
general lady from georgia who does not
mention ukraine once
she does not mention the thousands of
ukrainian civilians who've been
slaughtered by putin's army she does not
mention more than 100 ukrainian children
who've been shot and killed by the
ukrainian army instead she talks about a
massive invasion
at the border a massive invasion which
their own speakers have said today
hundreds of thousands of people have
been apprehended it
that's very different from a military
invasion the one in ukraine of course
the gentlelady's not going to talk about
that
she had a lot to say the other day when
she heckled me continuously
when i came to the floor it was like the
rocky horror picture show in here with
her chanting about the russia hoax and
russia this and russia that
now she had the opportunity to tell the
world what her views about russia are i
put them out there exactly what she has
said she said that the aid that the
taxpayers of america are sending to the
people of ukraine to defend themselves
against vladimir putin and the russian
army falls into the hands of nazis i
want to see your proof
where's our evidence
talks about
nato nazis
does my minority believe that our allies
in nato who are trying to defend the
people of ukraine are nazis has it come
to this
gentlelady talked about a massive
invasion we had a massive invasion of
our own chamber
and she continued to be a cheerleader
for the insurrection
and deny what happened here
so at the very end there um and you
don't hear it on this particular video
but at the very end
someone stands up and asks for for his
comments about the insurrection to be
stricken from the record forget about
all the other stuff they well i mean
they want his whole his whole statement
but they're very concerned about the
insurrection statement and the reason
why the reason why is because that's
part of the [ __ ] conversation they're
having down and the judges making
decision in georgia the administrative
judge that we watched last week for
eight hours on a live stream make a
decision about her being on the ballot
whether she's an insurrectionist or not
and jamie raskin puts it in public
record right there not only that she he
absolutely burns her to the ground um
which is fantastic this this [ __ ]
nonsense where they run around
spreading putin's propaganda all over
the place um it's no wonder that they're
against making sure that the american
people aid the ukrainians in their fight
against a murderous dictator who wants
to take away their sovereign nation and
their democracy by by by the house
debating 33 billion dollars that
president biden wants to make sure that
we help defend ukraine but not just
ukraine but democracy all around the
world because that's the thing that
putin is doing he's any
biden has said it time and time again
putin is not anyone's [ __ ] friend
because he is out to destroy democracy
yes he's doing it to ukraine because
that's one of the closest democracies
that he can actually launch bombs in and
commit war crimes in but he is hell-bent
on doing that everywhere and and the
united states and and president biden
and it looks like the house and
hopefully the senate will get off their
ass to do this will aid them in 33
billion dollars but marjorie taylor
green is coming to the floor of the
house to argue
that putin's good and you shouldn't use
33 billion dollars to help defend
democracy
doesn't even mention does not mention
ukraine right the whole the whole topic
is like can we should we give a to
ukraine to defend their democracy and
make sure that this genocide uh doesn't
actually go forward right they actually
have some defense like i don't know
that's not a crazy idea uh well she just
does the normal racist things and and
talks about brown people on the border
coming across
and that's the other thing
earlier this week she goes on that video
and says the catholic church is actually
run by satan and actually we should be
good christians and they believe
christians are those who care for for
people who are seeking refuge which is
like that's literally in the bible
that's literally what jesus taught he
said you know put shelter you know give
them food you know give them give them
security you know care for love your
love thy neighbor like this is something
that is is completely hypocritical
of the republican party and this is
another example we've got a dictator
committing genocide against ukrainians
putin is killing ukrainians and marger
taylor green goes well is putin really
the bad guy and it's like right what are
you what are you doing does he eat dogs
does he eat dogs you don't you don't
that's right does he does he eat dogs uh
you know does he do this did he make you
did he make your your boss fire you
because at the end of the day it is that
moment of like you're looking at someone
who is killing others which
just stop the just stop it right there
like that should not that no one should
be okay with that war crimes i mean
right and what she's saying in this
moment is like well you know uh it's
justified like it's [ __ ] random but
that's what the border but the border
like we have to worry about you know you
know what's funny about that
before we go to more hypocrisy here
because i want to point out the
hypocrisy in this video that you found
somewhere on the deep deep dark web i
think um
but donald trump was supposed to fix the
board do you remember that you're
supposed to build a wall in new york
yeah and he said mexico was gonna pay
for it yeah i think anyways anyways uh
speaking of hypocrisy my family in
mexico uh laughs at that [ __ ] all the
time because you're like it's a big fan
they're like we're not paying for that
[ __ ] yeah you can kiss my ass um here's
a video that you found somewhere on the
deep dart wood possibly of marjory
taylor green perjuring yourself but also
maybe receiving some information in her
ear during your testimony last friday
let's listen in did you advocate for
president trump to impose martial law as
a way to remain in power marge tell him
i don't recall ms green you've had your
disagreements with speaker pelosi isn't
that right do we have an answer huh i
need to give her an answer what are you
doing i'm keeping a count of how many
times she says she can't recall while i
wait for matt gates to text me the
question wait wait why is matt gates
texting you the question you said we
needed a man on the inside yeah as in a
cameraman to give us a live feed oh
yeah i should probably tell gates he can
take up his bull profession oh my god
just tell me if she said it uh i don't
think so marge just said no i haven't
said that okay
put up pennies exhibit five please where
is the lawyer going with this oh no she
did what and she liked a facebook
comment that said a bullet to the head
would be quicker in order to remove
house speaker nancy pelosi oh [ __ ] uh
marge tell him oh no wait
hold on now that was close oh nice guess
what what she beat eric trump's record
so i don't know where you found this
video at but this is a great video
evidence of her hypocrisy yeah yeah i
mean i would not be surprised if she
actually had a had a uh earpiece in
would you i would yeah
i would be saying
they accuse democrats of it all the time
and it's typical projection i don't know
all i'm going to say is on the on the
situation that happened during that that
that hearing she was very quick to
answer certain things now obviously she
was probably coached to say certain
things but the response that she had to
certain questions
i almost
want to say
she had someone talking to her ear with
a little earpiece maybe maybe i don't
know well that's how you that's the your
ear pieces the new ear pieces that you
have those are soros earpieces right
yeah these are coming straight from
george soros okay good and every time i
talk i just hear like ching chi ching
ching okay it seems just deposited oh
that's good that's good yeah yeah okay
that's good that's good well we all need
that let's give let's give the bone hand
of the week her do here let's
mj wanted to hear the jingle so here we
go
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah marjorie taylor green is the
bonenette of the week again thank you
everyone for participating in the bone
end of the week go follow at
tonymichaelspod
on twitter to find the poll of bonnet of
the week and subscribe to the youtube
channel because it sounds like the chat
is gonna make gabe sanchez our executive
producer and the runner the runner and
executor of the bone of the weak pole
and the graphics put it up on youtube i
heard i heard a couple i heard a couple
people in the chat say not everyone has
twitter so i will
accommodate the youtube population
uh but you know if you want more people
to vote on the poll make sure to share
the video make sure to subscribe
get the word out do all those things do
all those things for us here and this
has been this has been your edition
don't stick around we're gonna have a
couple announcements right after this
this has been your edition
because you voted and we broke it down a
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]